is a liar and the bride is a shield the priest says if these two don't make it who among us ever will don't ask the love you dare for a prediction
是骗子，而新娘是挡箭牌。牧师说，如果这两个人都走不到最后，我们之中还有谁能做到呢？别去问你敢于去爱的那个预测。
wherein the lovers of tomorrow are involved I guess time just makes fools of us all Hey guys, it's Joel with the Tapute Therapy Collective podcast, and this is the second part of the Mirror World episode. So I want to talk about Gnosticism, if anyone's familiar with it. In the second century, there's this sect of Christianity that sort of emerges, and the followers of it believe that the world we inhabited was not created by the real,
其中涉及了未来的恋人。我想时间只是把我们都变成了傻瓜。大家好，我是Joel，这是Tapute治疗集体播客，这是“镜像世界”这一集的第二部分。所以我想谈谈诺斯替教，如果有人熟悉它的话。在二世纪，出现了一个基督教派别，其追随者认为我们所居住的世界并非由真正的……
God. There was a real God and they were Christians, but that the world that we were inhabiting sort of had a fake God, um, chaperoning it. And that the message of Jesus and the mission of Christians was to break through into the real world, um, to meet the real God. And it was made, you know, the bad world was made by this creature called the Demiurge. And it was responsible for all of material reality. But the Demiurge had dementia. It kind of forgotten who it was. And so, you know, it was this creature that was a creation of, you know, the true God, but because of a kind of cosmic mix-up, it lost its identity, and it ended up on the middle of where we are. And so it created the world and decided, well, I must have created everything because I don't remember anything else,
上帝所创造。确实有一位真正的上帝，他们也是基督徒，但我们所居住的世界是由一位伪神在……监管着。耶稣的信息和基督徒的使命是突破到真实的世界，去遇见真正的上帝。这个糟糕的世界是由一个叫“德米乌尔格”（Demiurge）的生物创造的。它负责所有的物质现实。但德米乌尔格患有痴呆症。它有点忘记了自己是谁。所以，你知道，它是一个由真神创造的生物，但由于某种宇宙性的混乱，它失去了身份，最终落在了我们所处的中间地带。于是它创造了世界，并断定：好吧，我一定创造了一切，因为我不记得其他任何东西了，
and now I'm here. And so, you know, its blindness was sort of metaphorically similar to our blindness and that it became this tyrant of the Old Testament, you know. And this is all later, you know, made heretical and taken out of Christianity. There's not Christians that know this theology today. I'm not advocating for the theology. I'm using it as a metaphor here. But it wasn't a fringe movement. You know, it was a major current of early religious thought. And at some point, you know, there were a lot of people, you know, maybe the majority of the faith that had elements of these schools of thought and how they thought. And so, you know, the Gnostics were trying to solve this problem
现在我在这里。所以，你知道，它的盲目在隐喻上类似于我们的盲目，它变成了旧约中的那种暴君。这一切后来都被定为异端，并从基督教中剔除。今天没有基督徒了解这种神学。我并不是在提倡这种神学。我只是把它作为一个隐喻。但它并不是一个边缘运动。你知道，它是早期宗教思想的一个主要流派。在某种程度上，有很多人，也许是大多数信徒，他们的思维方式中都有这些思想流派的元素。所以，诺斯替教徒试图解决这个问题，
that people today are still trying to solve, or theologians are still trying to solve where they say, if God's good and all-powerful, why is the world so full of suffering? You know, why do kids get sick? Why do the innocent suffer, you know, while wicked prosper? And why is their evil? And so the Orthodox answer is that there's, you know, free will and fallen nature and,
今天的人们仍在试图解决，或者神学家们仍在试图解决，他们说：如果上帝是善良且全能的，为什么世界充满了苦难？你知道，为什么孩子们会生病？为什么无辜者受苦，而邪恶者却繁荣？为什么会有邪恶？所以正统的回答是，有自由意志、堕落的本性，以及……
a mysterious divine plan that never, you know, quite is satisfying for some people. That's what you get after the Council of Nicaea when Christianity is kind of codified. But before that, you know, the Gnostics are offering way before that. The Gnostics are offering this, you know, more radical idea that the world is full of suffering because the world was made by a being who didn't know what he was doing. And it's why in the Old Testament sometimes God or the false God behaves badly, as the Gnostics would tell you, he's wrathful or vindictive or has qualities they wouldn't associate with goodness. And so the Demirge, who's the false God with dementia that thinks he created the earth, but he actually didn't.
一个神秘的神圣计划，这对于某些人来说永远无法令人满意。这就是尼西亚公会议之后，基督教被编纂成法典时你所得到的东西。但在那之前，诺斯替教徒提供了一种更激进的想法：世界充满苦难是因为世界是由一个不知道自己在做什么的生物创造的。这就是为什么在旧约中，上帝或伪神有时表现得很糟糕，正如诺斯替教徒会告诉你的那样，他愤怒、报复心强，或者具有他们不会与善良联系在一起的品质。所以德米乌尔格，那个患有痴呆症、认为自己创造了地球但实际上并没有的伪神。
You know, he's not really evil. He was just confused because he was this fragment of divine light that had fallen from its source and it no longer remembered its origin. And so in this confusion, he created the material world as if it were the only reality. And he declared, I'm God. And there is no other. And this is why Gnostics identified the Demiurge with the God of the Old Testament, that he was jealous and wrathful. and he demanded obedience and punished followers, or not followers, followers who went astray.
你知道，他并不是真的邪恶。他只是感到困惑，因为他是一片从源头坠落的神圣光芒的碎片，不再记得自己的起源。因此，在这种困惑中，他创造了物质世界，仿佛它是唯一的现实。他宣称：“我是上帝，没有其他上帝。”这就是为什么诺斯替教徒将德米乌尔格与旧约中的上帝等同起来，认为他嫉妒、愤怒，要求服从并惩罚追随者，或者说，惩罚那些误入歧途的追随者。
Foods and floods, plagues, and sometimes food. And so it seemed very different than the loving father that Jesus, you know, describes. And so the Gnostics say, that's not the Trugon. That's the confused creator who thinks that he's the only one. And, you know, this also lets you deal with all these ideas that Plato had, you know, let loose. Plato's already talking about the real world being fake, and if you're in Plato's cave, you see only shadow figures of the real thing. And so it sort of lets everyone put the zeitgeist and cultural currents and thought, you know, leading, cutting edge, thought of the Bronx Age together into this way that makes it all work together a little bit better.
洪水、瘟疫，有时还有食物。所以这看起来与耶稣所描述的慈爱的父亲非常不同。因此，诺斯替教徒说，那不是真神。那是困惑的创造者，他认为自己是唯一的一个。而且，这也能让你处理柏拉图所释放的所有这些想法。柏拉图已经在谈论真实世界是虚假的，如果你在柏拉图的洞穴里，你只能看到真实事物的影子。所以这让每个人都能把时代精神、文化潮流和青铜时代的前沿思想结合在一起，让这一切运作得更好一点。
And so the Gnostics, you know, take the Platonism and they make it religious. The material world isn't just inferior to the spiritual world. It's actually a trap. This is a prison. The body isn't the temple of the soul. it's the soul's cage. You're on a planet that is a prison. If you recognize the phrase prison planet, if you're about my age, then you probably are starting to see where I'm going with us, because that's something that the radio conspiracy, you know, right-wing guy, Alex Jones, you know,
所以诺斯替教徒把柏拉图主义宗教化了。物质世界不仅逊色于精神世界，它实际上是一个陷阱。这是一个监狱。身体不是灵魂的殿堂，它是灵魂的牢笼。你身处一颗监狱星球上。如果你认出“监狱星球”这个词，如果你和我年纪差不多，那么你可能开始明白我的意思了，因为那是广播阴谋论者、右翼人士亚历克斯·琼斯（Alex Jones）所说的……
says, because these ideas don't really go away, the Gnostic ideas. That's why I'm bringing them up. You know, so, you know, human beings, you know, according to Gnosticism, they can, contain within them these sparks of the origin light, you know, of God. And, you know, we could feel even if it, you know, even if we couldn't articulate it, that the Demiurge's world was not complete, that something really beyond it. And something had been lost. We had this sort of divine inheritance that was not here. And some of the language in the Bible sort of supported that, or was used to cite these ideas at that time. And so, the multiple writings that hadn't really been codified into the Bible yet. But, you know, this inward turn, you know, this sense that the truth lies
因为这些想法并没有真正消失，这就是我提到它们的原因。所以，根据诺斯替教，人类内心包含着这些起源之光的火花，也就是上帝的光。而且，即使我们无法表达出来，我们也能感觉到德米乌尔格的世界是不完整的，在它之外确实存在着某种东西。有些东西已经丢失了。我们拥有这种不属于这里的神圣遗产。圣经中的一些语言在某种程度上支持了这一点，或者在当时被用来引用这些想法。所以，那些尚未被编纂进圣经的多部著作。但是，这种向内的转向，这种认为真理存在于……
within rather than an external authority. It was kind of dangerous, you know, to certain orders. It was a neat gift, you know, that Gnostics gave people to think about, you know, these things in a way that was more personal and not like asking for someone to save me, but going inside so that I can connect with salvation myself. You know, but the danger was that it could lead to rejection of the body, you know, you're not taking care at yourself, asceticism, of community, and also some of the material conditions of life. You know, the gift is that it says that each person has direct access to the divine and that no institution could monopolize the path to truth and that the inner life mattered as much as the outer. And that, you know, it was the job of Christians to build communities
内心而非外部权威的感觉。这对某些秩序来说是危险的。诺斯替教徒给人们提供了一份精美的礼物，让他们以一种更个人的方式思考这些事情，而不是要求某人来拯救我，而是向内探索，以便我自己能与救赎建立联系。但是，危险在于它可能导致对身体的排斥，比如你不照顾自己、禁欲主义、脱离社区，以及对生活中的一些物质条件的忽视。这份礼物的意义在于，它说每个人都有直接接触神性的途径，没有任何机构可以垄断通往真理的道路，内在生活与外在生活同样重要。而且，基督徒的工作是建立社区，
that pointed people inward, that that's what the church should be. That's an idea that would become very threatening, you know, to the modern medieval church. and are modern from this time, not our time. You know, the word Gnosticism comes from nosis, which just means knowledge, you know, not facts or information, but direct experience of what is real. And the Gnostics believed that we were trapped in a false reality
引导人们向内看，那才是教会应该有的样子。这个想法对现代中世纪教会来说变得非常有威胁。（这里的“现代”是指那个时代，而不是我们这个时代。）“诺斯替主义”（Gnosticism）这个词来自“诺斯”（nosis），意思就是知识，不是事实或信息，而是对真实事物的直接体验。诺斯替教徒相信我们被困在一个虚假的现实中，
and that salvation meant waking up to what the Demiurges world had hidden from us, going back home to where we came from. And the early church rebranded, you know, that as heresy. You said most of the Gnostic texts are destroyed. You know, if you have anything harassed, radical you're in trouble. So for centuries, Gnosticism survived, you know, kind of as a rumor or a memory, you know, oral teaching, or it survived in ideas of people that didn't really understand
而救赎意味着从德米乌尔格的世界向我们隐瞒的东西中醒来，回到我们来的地方。早期教会将其重新定义为异端。你说大多数诺斯替文本都被销毁了。如果你有任何激进的东西，你就有麻烦了。所以几个世纪以来，诺斯替主义以谣言或记忆、口头教导的形式幸存下来，或者它存在于那些并不真正理解……
the inheritance that they were carrying on. And then in 1945, there's this jar discovered near Nag Hammadi in Egypt. And inside were Gnostic Gospels and treatises. And they were hidden for 2,000 years. The heresy had preserved itself because somebody had hidden it away, you know, probably during one of the purges. And I wanted to use Gnosticism. as a frame for what I'm about to describe the second part of the Mirror World episode. Maybe you're starting to make that connection already because I think it's not literally true.
他们所承载的遗产的人的思想中。然后在1945年，在埃及的纳格哈马迪附近发现了一个罐子。里面装的是诺斯替福音书和论文。它们被隐藏了2000年。异端邪说得以自我保存，因为有人把它藏了起来，可能是在某次清洗期间。我想用诺斯替主义作为框架，来描述“镜像世界”这一集的第二部分。也许你已经开始建立这种联系了，因为我认为它在字面上并不真实。
I'm not a Gnostic. There were some semi-modern Gnostics like the writer Philip K. Dick. You know, people end up there. Well, creative people and nefarious, other people like Alex Jones who kind of co-opt this language. But this structure of this maps
我不是诺斯替教徒。有一些半现代的诺斯替教徒，比如作家菲利普·K·迪克（Philip K. Dick）。人们最终会走到那里。好吧，有创造力的人和邪恶的人，比如亚历克斯·琼斯这样的人，他们会借用这种语言。但这种结构映射……
onto our contemporary situation with kind of an uncomfortable precision because we built institutions that were supposed to reflect truth, reality, you know, the real thing. Science, education, economic, psychology, journalism, expertise, you know, itself. The hierarchies of this person's at this point above you because they know more about something. Specialization. And then these were our instruments for perceiving what's true. And they were supposed to be windows into a real world, the democracy.
到我们当下的处境中，有一种令人不安的精确性，因为我们建立的机构本应反映真理、现实，也就是真实的东西。科学、教育、经济、心理学、新闻学、专业知识本身。这些等级制度——这个人比你高，因为他们对某事了解更多。专业化。这些是我们感知真理的工具。它们本应是通向真实世界的窗口，民主……
expertise for people who didn't have it through appointing experts and systems that acted as experts. But these windows became mirrored at a certain point. The institutions were meant to represent reality, but they became disconnected from it. And now we mistake the representation for the thing itself. The Demiurge isn't the algorithm, and the Demiurge is the whole system of professional legitimacy that forgot it was supposed to point back to reality, not to numbers that no longer reflected reality accurately. But when all you can see is the numbers, all you can see is that demergic world. And the only way you believe that you have to change yourself or that you have to
通过任命专家和作为专家的系统，为那些没有专业知识的人提供专业知识。但在某个时刻，这些窗口变成了镜子。这些机构本应代表现实，但它们与现实脱节了。现在我们把表象误认为是事物本身。德米乌尔格不是算法，德米乌尔格是整个专业合法性体系，它忘记了它本应指向现实，而不是指向那些不再准确反映现实的数字。但当你只能看到数字时，你只能看到那个德米乌尔格式的世界。而你认为改变自己或改变世界的唯一途径……
change the world are through these fake systems that no longer connect to the real. How do you change anything? You know, experts would study the world before carefully and then report what they found. Science, you know, scientists, when they tested hypotheses, they would publish results. An economist would model the economy to help us understand it. Psychologists would develop frameworks for thinking about the mind. And educators would assess students to see what they'd learned. Journalists would investigate and tell us what was true. And the credentials, the peer review, the standardized measures, these were supposed to be quality controls, ways to ensure that, you know,
是通过这些不再与现实连接的虚假系统。你如何改变任何事情？你知道，专家们过去会仔细研究世界，然后报告他们的发现。科学，科学家们在测试假设时会发表结果。经济学家会模拟经济来帮助我们理解它。心理学家会开发思考心灵的框架。教育工作者会评估学生以了解他们学到了什么。记者会调查并告诉我们什么是真的。而证书、同行评审、标准化衡量标准，这些本应是质量控制，是确保……
what the institution said reflected what was actually happening. And the representation was meant to serve the reality. And for a while, something like this worked, not perfectly. Institutions have always been flawed and always had blind spots and biases. But the connection between representation and reality was still visible and then it was the goal of the organization. Not the other way around. Not to change the world by changing the representation, which is what we're trying to do now. Remember in the early 90s, I was a kid.
机构所说的反映了实际发生的事情的方法。表象本应服务于现实。有一段时间，这样的事情是有效的，虽然不完美。机构一直都有缺陷，一直都有盲点和偏见。但表象与现实之间的联系仍然可见，那是组织的目标。而不是反过来。不是通过改变表象来改变世界，这正是我们现在试图做的。记得90年代初，我还是个孩子。
but I was talking to somebody about like, why do people think that these very clear models of, you know, economic direction that we're going in work? Because we see the more we adopt them, they get worse, you know. I was talking about politics. And the person said, I was a dinner party with all these people, and they believe something different about economics than me. And they were talking about how, you know, all the people in their life are so bad with money and their hairdresser and their wife and their kids and nobody understands it.
但我当时在和某人谈论，为什么人们认为我们正在走的这些非常清晰的经济方向模型是有效的？因为我们看到我们采用得越多，情况就越糟。我当时在谈论政治。那个人说，我在一个晚宴上，在座的所有人对经济的看法都和我不同。他们谈论着他们生活中的所有人对金钱的处理是多么糟糕，他们的理发师、他们的妻子、他们的孩子，没有人理解它。
And then they would espouse these models that under the economy, everyone acts logically, rationally, in the self-interested way to drive this beautiful engine forward. And the guy said, I said to the party of people, hey, you just said no one does that. And then you said that the only way forward for the economy is to do it by this model assuming that they do, why. And everybody just kind of looked at their wine glass for a minute. And they couldn't justify what they believed. And then they went back to talking. It's always stuck with me. You know, when this map has diverged too far from the territory, people can't see.
然后他们会支持这些模型，认为在经济中，每个人都逻辑地、理性地、以自利的方式行事，推动这台美丽的引擎前进。那个人说，我对那群人说：“嘿，你们刚才说没有人那样做。然后你们又说经济前进的唯一途径是按照这个模型，假设他们那样做，为什么？”每个人都盯着他们的酒杯看了一会儿。他们无法证明他们所相信的东西。然后他们又继续谈话。这总是让我印象深刻。你知道，当这张地图与领土偏离太远时，人们就看不见了。
The problem with comparing and contrasting things is that you need both of the things visible. When one of the things gets too far away from the other thing, then that's all you can see. So you can't really compare and contrast anymore. And that's what happened. As these systems moved further and further away from what they were supposed to do, we stopped listening to any of the cognitive dissonance, any of the emotion. overwhelm any of the gut feeling that these things weren't real anymore and we just decided that it was all that we could see and so that it's all that it was it's kind of like the joke about the drunk under the
比较和对比事物的困难在于，你需要让两样东西都可见。当其中一样东西离另一样东西太远时，那就是你所能看到的全部。所以你无法再进行比较和对比了。这就是发生的事情。随着这些系统离它们本应做的事情越来越远，我们不再听取任何认知失调、任何情绪的淹没、任何这些东西不再真实的直觉，我们只是决定这就是我们所能看到的一切，所以这就是它的一切。这有点像那个关于醉汉在……
lamp lamp I heard a talk where noam Chomsky told that joke and he said you know that there's a guy who's drunk and he's looking under the streetlight for his keys and the guy says why are you looking on this side of the road because it's you know got this street light here did you drop your keys there The guy said, no, I dropped him on the other side of the road. And the guy said, well, why don't you look on the other side of the road for your keys? And he said, because the other side of the road's dark, this is where the light is. I can't see anything over there. You know, I talked about Theodore Porter quite a bit, but, you know, one of the points that is continually relevant that he makes is that the disciplines that quantify,
路灯下找钥匙的笑话。我听过一个演讲，诺姆·乔姆斯基（Noam Chomsky）讲过那个笑话，他说，有一个醉汉在路灯下找钥匙，有人问他：“你为什么在路的那一边找？”“因为这里有路灯。”“你把钥匙掉在那边了吗？”那人说：“没有，我掉在路的那一边了。”那人说：“那你为什么不去路的那一边找钥匙？”他说：“因为路的那边很黑，这里有光。我那边什么也看不见。”你知道，我谈论过西奥多·波特（Theodore Porter）很多次，但他提出的一个持续相关的观点是，那些量化程度……
most heavily, aren't the confident disciplines. They're the vulnerable ones, economics, psychology, sociology, education. There are fields that are under attack, fields that, lack the prestige of physics or chemistry. Fields where practitioners feel that they have to prove that the science that they're doing is real. Well, if they want to do it, they should know that already. Porter showed how this works historically, the U.S. Army Corps of Engineer. They didn't develop cost-benefit analysis because it was the best way to evaluate flood control. In fact, sometimes it makes that project harder. They developed it because Congress didn't trust them with money. The
最严重的学科，并不是自信的学科。它们是脆弱的学科：经济学、心理学、社会学、教育学。这些领域受到攻击，缺乏物理学或化学的声望。从业者感到他们必须证明他们所做的科学是真实的。好吧，如果他们想做，他们应该已经知道了。波特展示了这在历史上是如何运作的，美国陆军工程兵团。他们开发成本效益分析并不是因为它评估防洪的最佳方式。事实上，有时它会让项目变得更难。他们开发它是因为国会不信任他们的资金使用。这些……
numbers were a shield against political attack. Every decision could be defended by pointing to a calculation. The more insecure the field, the more it retreats behind numbers. Not because numbers work better. Often they work worse, but because numbers provide legitimacy, the appearance of objectivity, defense against critics. And as a writer, I can tell you that when you are creating things for your critics, it's not going to be very good.
数字是抵御政治攻击的盾牌。每一个决定都可以通过指向一个计算结果来辩护。领域越不安全，它就越退缩到数字背后。不是因为数字效果更好。通常它们效果更差，但因为数字提供了合法性、客观性的表象、对批评者的防御。作为一名作家，我可以告诉你，当你为批评者创作东西时，它不会很好。
Here's the trap. the more that an institution depends on the metric and systems of metrics for legitimacy, the more it has to protect that metric from scrutiny. You can't admit that the measure is flawed because the measure is all you have. We talked in the DSM series about the three meetings after the DSM three was written, where they basically agreed that the system didn't work, but that they couldn't change it because too much was tough. to that system.
这就是陷阱。一个机构越依赖指标和指标系统来获得合法性，它就越必须保护该指标免受审查。你不能承认衡量标准是有缺陷的，因为衡量标准是你所拥有的全部。我们在DSM系列中谈到了DSM-3编写后的三次会议，他们基本上同意该系统不起作用，但他们无法改变它，因为太多的东西与该系统挂钩了。
And you can't question the test because the test is what makes you an expert. You know, Porter traced this to a strange discovery in the 19th century, astronomy, the personal equation. Different observers measuring the same stellar transit got different results. And the same reality produced different numbers depending on who was watching. The response was telling. Instead of accepting that trade judgment varies, that expertise involves personal skill,
你不能质疑测试，因为测试是你成为专家的原因。你知道，波特将此追溯到19世纪天文学的一个奇怪发现：个人方程。不同的观察者测量相同的恒星凌日得到不同的结果。同一个现实产生了不同的数字，取决于谁在观察。反应很能说明问题。他们没有接受判断力会因人而异，没有接受专业知识涉及个人技能，
maybe that science is half art and half science, or at least some measure. They built machines, and they replaced human observation with automated recording. And they eliminated the observer. And this is the birth of mechanical objectivity, the dream of knowledge untouched by human judgment, numbers that measure themselves, truth without perspective. But Porter discovered something crucial. The disciplines that rely the most heavily on mechanical objectivity aren't the strongest. elite physicians at CERN don't use rigid protocols.
也许科学一半是艺术，一半是科学，或者至少某种衡量标准。他们制造了机器，用自动记录取代了人类观察。他们消除了观察者。这就是机械客观性的诞生，一种不受人类判断影响的知识梦想，自我衡量的数字，没有视角的真理。但波特发现了一些至关重要的东西。最依赖机械客观性的学科并不是最强大的。欧洲核子研究中心（CERN）的精英物理学家不使用僵化的协议。
They trust trained judgment. They have what Porter calls disciplinary objectivity, the confidence that comes from secure professional community. The weak disciplines retreat into mechanical objectivity precisely because they're weak. They build elaborate quantitative systems, not because numbers work better, but because numbers defend against attack,
他们信任训练有素的判断力。他们拥有波特所说的“学科客观性”，即来自安全专业社区的自信。弱势学科退缩到机械客观性正是因为它们软弱。它们构建复杂的定量系统，不是因为数字效果更好，而是因为数字可以抵御攻击，
and checklists are a form of number. Adam Curtis, with what we mentioned to New York in the last episode, he documented something different. The profit motive and the assumptions baked into the infrastructure of governance itself, even representative governance. What Curtis showed across his films is how the economic order that emerged in the 1970s, neoliberalism, didn't just impose policies. It imposed a model.
而清单也是一种数字。亚当·柯蒂斯（Adam Curtis），我们在上一集中提到的，他记录了一些不同的东西。利润动机和治理基础设施本身所固有的假设，甚至是代议制治理。柯蒂斯在他的电影中展示的是，1970年代出现的经济秩序——新自由主义——不仅仅是强加政策。它强加了一个模型。
When the bankers took over New York in 1975, they didn't just demand austerity. They demanded that the city be governed according to their spreadsheet. The model contained assumptions that a city exists to service bond obligations, that human welfare is a cost to be minimized, that the market's judgment is the only judgment that matters. And those assumptions weren't debated. They were built into the calculations. They became the operating system. Curtis traced how this spread. You know, the Nixon shock in 1971 took the dollar off gold, turning currencies into free-floating abstract.
当银行家在1975年接管纽约时，他们不仅仅要求紧缩。他们要求城市按照他们的电子表格来管理。该模型包含了一些假设：城市的存在是为了偿还债券义务，人类福利是需要最小化的成本，市场的判断是唯一重要的判断。而这些假设并没有被辩论。它们被内置到了计算中。它们成为了操作系统。柯蒂斯追踪了它是如何传播的。你知道，1971年的尼克松冲击使美元与黄金脱钩，将货币变成了自由浮动的抽象概念。
the banks could trade. The politicians faced with systems too complex to control, stopped trying to shape reality and started becoming managers of the representation of reality. They started dealing with aesthetics, how reality looked, instead of reality itself, especially material reality. How much do you have to eat? How much is a dollar worth? How is the quality of the education that your kids get? If you have cancer, can you go to the doctor? And more crucially to this podcast, what is psychotherapy and what is it? its job, what is the nature of self, and what is the nature of healthy? They became, as political scientist, Peter Mayer put it, managers of processes that they could no longer direct, representing
银行可以进行交易。政客们面对过于复杂而无法控制的系统，停止了试图塑造现实，开始成为现实表象的管理者。他们开始处理美学，即现实看起来如何，而不是现实本身，尤其是物质现实。你需要吃多少？一美元值多少钱？你孩子接受的教育质量如何？如果你得了癌症，你能去看医生吗？更关键的是，什么是心理治疗，它的工作是什么，自我的本质是什么，健康的本质是什么？正如政治学家彼得·梅尔（Peter Mair）所说，他们成为了他们无法再指导的流程的管理者，向人民代表……
power to the people, rather than representing the people to power. And once the assumptions are infrastructure, the profit motive takes over. You don't need a conspiracy. You just need incentives. You don't even need propaganda anymore. The testing companies profit from testing, so testing expands. The financing sector profits from complexity. So complexity increases. The tech platforms profit from engagement. So engagement gets optimized at the expense of everything else, like news or reality. Curtis calls this the retreat into a fake world. Politicians moved the red ribbon on the map and they called it victory. They optimized the metrics and they ignored the territory. This creates what Curtis documents as a bifurcated world.
权力，而不是向权力代表人民。一旦假设成为基础设施，利润动机就会接管。你不需要阴谋。你只需要激励。你甚至不再需要宣传。测试公司从测试中获利，所以测试范围扩大。金融部门从复杂性中获利。所以复杂性增加。科技平台从参与度中获利。所以参与度被优化，牺牲了其他一切，比如新闻或现实。柯蒂斯称之为“退缩到虚假世界”。政客们移动了地图上的红丝带，称之为胜利。他们优化了指标，忽略了领土。这创造了柯蒂斯所记录的二元世界。
the measurements and the models of professional legitimacy. And then the actual world, which goes increasingly unattended by any adults. The fake world is where careers happen, where credentials matter, where the metrics determine success. The real world is where the factories close, where the climate destabilizes, where the people who feel the gap between their experience and the official story live. The profit motive ensures that the fake world keeps expanding. There's money in metrics.
专业合法性的衡量标准和模型。然后是现实世界，它越来越无人问津。虚假世界是职业生涯发生的地方，是证书重要的地方，是指标决定成功的地方。现实世界是工厂关闭的地方，是气候不稳定、感受到经验与官方叙事之间差距的人们生活的地方。利润动机确保了虚假世界不断扩张。指标里有钱。
There's money in credentials. There's money in the apparatus of professional legitimacy. There's no money in territory. The territory is a cost center. And the assumptions ensure that we can't see what's happening. If the model assumes rational actors, then irrational actors. Irrational behavior must be an anomaly to be corrected, not a signal to be heard. And if the model assumes that markets are efficient, then market failures are temporary glitches, not structural features.
证书里有钱。专业合法性的机构里有钱。领土里没钱。领土是一个成本中心。而这些假设确保了我们无法看到正在发生的事情。如果模型假设参与者是理性的，那么非理性的行为必须是一个需要纠正的异常，而不是一个需要听取的信号。如果模型假设市场是有效的，那么市场失灵就是暂时的故障，而不是结构性特征。
If the model assumes the metrics capture what matters, then what the metrics miss doesn't exist. And this is how you get cut off from the real, not by lying, but by building systems that literally cannot perceive what it is not designed to measure. And then making that system the only source of legitimacy. And the incentives point everyone towards the mirror. The assumptions make the territory invisible. And the generation after that generation grows up inside a faker and faker world, never knowing that there was supposed to be something on the other side. And here's what I want you to see. These systems pretend to understand you.
如果模型假设指标捕捉到了重要的事情，那么指标遗漏的东西就不存在。这就是你如何与现实隔绝的，不是通过撒谎，而是通过建立无法感知其未被设计去衡量的东西的系统。然后使该系统成为合法性的唯一来源。激励措施引导每个人走向镜子。假设使领土变得不可见。而那一代人之后的一代人在越来越虚假的世界中长大，从未知道另一边本应存在着什么。这就是我想让你看到的。这些系统假装了解你。
They pretend to help us change. They pretend to give us tools for evaluating the world. But they don't actually do any of those things. They do imitations of those things, and the imitations cut us off further from what actually is real. The diagnostic and statistical manual of mental health disorders was supposed to help clinicians understand patients. It was supposed to be a tool, a shared vocabulary,
它们假装帮助我们改变。它们假装给我们提供评估世界的工具。但它们实际上并没有做任何这些事情。它们做的是这些事情的模仿，而这些模仿使我们进一步与真实的东西隔绝。精神健康障碍诊断与统计手册（DSM）本应帮助临床医生了解患者。它本应是一个工具，一个共享的词汇表，
for describing the variation of human suffering so that practitioners could communicate and research could accumulate. But the DSM became something else, like we discussed in that series. It became the definition of what mental illness is. If your suffering fits a code, it's real. If it doesn't, it's not.
用于描述人类苦难的变化，以便从业者可以交流，研究可以积累。但DSM变成了别的东西，就像我们在那个系列中讨论的那样。它成为了精神疾病定义的标准。如果你的痛苦符合一个代码，它就是真实的。如果不符合，它就不是。
That would be a problem, but then something further happened. And I want to be clear because a lot of people get angry that I won't critique the DSM on those grounds. I'm not saying that a manual could encompass all of these things in a way that honors your humanity. That argument's already been made. I'm making a different one.
那会是一个问题，但后来发生了更进一步的事情。我想说清楚，因为很多人因为我不愿在这些基础上批评DSM而感到愤怒。我并不是说一本手册可以以一种尊重你人性的方式涵盖所有这些事情。那个论点已经有人提过了。我提出的是另一个论点。
Not that that isn't a problem. There's a problem that is bigger. You have three times where people sat down and they realized that the DSM still wasn't reliable. You had multiple psychiatrists. You had multiple therapists all seeing patients with the same presentation, but calling it different things.
并不是说那不是一个问题。有一个更大的问题。你有三次人们坐下来，意识到DSM仍然不可靠。你有多个精神科医生。你有多个治疗师，他们都看到表现相同的患者，但称之为不同的东西。
So all of the changes to make that manual more reliable. How do you make sure that what they're talking, about when somebody comes in with this presentation, they end up with the same label put on them, made the labels further and further from what was valid or real. This is why the NIMH dumped the DSM and said this thing isn't pointing to anything that is biological, reproducible, or real. Stop using it. And again, I don't agree with all of their reasons for doing that. But it is what the Institute that is supposed to control our mental health science said after me. many years of clinical therapists saying the same thing.
所以为了使该手册更可靠而进行的所有更改。你如何确保当有人带着这种表现进来时，他们最终会被贴上相同的标签？这使得标签离有效或真实的东西越来越远。这就是为什么美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH）抛弃了DSM，并说这个东西并没有指向任何生物学上、可重复或真实的东西。停止使用它。再说一次，我并不完全同意他们这样做的所有理由。但这是那个本应控制我们心理健康科学的机构，在许多临床治疗师说了同样的话之后所说的。
The DSM pretends to help you change. Here's your diagnosis. Here's the treatment protocol. Here's the expected outcome. And all in the name of science. But the change it offers is an adjustment to the system that made you sick. They don't go back to the drawing board and realize that anxiety and depression usually appear at the same time.
DSM假装帮助你改变。这是你的诊断。这是治疗方案。这是预期的结果。一切都以科学的名义。但它提供的改变是对让你生病的系统的调整。他们不会回到绘图板，意识到焦虑和抑郁通常同时出现。
Maybe these are related diagnoses. They don't go back to what the symptoms are actually saying. They just go back to the same labels that we've always called these things and then move them around slowly. slightly because the label, the system, the reflection of reality is now more real than what the experience of the patient or the reproducible experiences of multiple human brains are telling the researchers. But we can't change it. In education, the tests were supposed to measure learning. They were supposed to help us understand what students knew so that we could teach them better.
也许这些是相关的诊断。他们不会回到症状实际上在说什么。他们只是回到我们一直称呼这些东西的相同标签，然后缓慢地移动它们。稍微移动一下，因为标签、系统、现实的反映现在比患者的体验或多个人类大脑的可重复体验告诉研究人员的东西更真实。但我们无法改变它。在教育中，测试本应衡量学习。它们本应帮助我们理解学生知道什么，以便我们能更好地教他们。
But the test became the definition of learning. What's on the test is what gets taught. What's not on the test doesn't exist. Teaching to the test isn't a corruption of education. It's what education has become. And if you taught something that wasn't on the test, you didn't teach anything. It wasn't real. The test prepare you to understand students. Here's a score that captures your ability, your potential, your place, and in hierarchy around certain metrics. The system knows what you're capable of. But the score doesn't know you. It doesn't know why you froze during the exam or what you understand deeply but can't express in multiple choice or what gifts you have. that no one tests to measure, or what strings that you have that have been unrecognized
但测试成为了学习的定义。测试上的东西就是被教的东西。测试上没有的东西就不存在。为测试而教并不是教育的腐败。这就是教育已经变成的样子。如果你教了一些测试上没有的东西，你就什么也没教。那不是真的。测试准备让你了解学生。这是一个捕捉你的能力、你的潜力、你在围绕某些指标的等级制度中的位置的分数。系统知道你的能力。但分数不了解你。它不知道为什么你在考试时僵住了，或者你深刻理解但无法用多项选择表达的东西，或者你有什么天赋。
because the system hasn't found the seed or the divine spark of those things, and you learned to help you know how to use them. The test pretends to offer mobility. Score high and doors open, the meritocracy will reward your ability, but the tests measure familiarity with testing. And familiarity with testing correlates with class background, with resources, with ability to buy preparation. The ACT doesn't really measure how prepared a student is for college. It doesn't measure how much they know. It doesn't measure anything that they learned from high school. It measures how much time, resources, and maybe forceful parents forced them to study for that test. And so we've started to accept these new things that don't point back to anything in reality as the gatekeeping
没有人测试去衡量，或者你有什么未被认可的特质，因为系统没有找到这些东西的种子或神圣火花，而你学会了帮助你知道如何使用它们。测试假装提供流动性。分数高，门就开了，精英管理制度会奖励你的能力，但测试衡量的是对测试的熟悉程度。而对测试的熟悉程度与阶级背景、资源、购买准备的能力相关。ACT并没有真正衡量学生为大学准备得如何。它不衡量他们知道多少。它不衡量他们从高中学到了什么。它衡量的是他们花了多少时间、资源，以及也许强迫性的父母强迫他们为那个测试学习了多少。所以我们开始接受这些不再指向现实中任何东西的新事物，作为现实本身的守门人，
for reality itself, even though they're not connected. And mainstream science and research tells us they're not connected anymore. And this is crucial. The systems don't just fail to help. They actively prevent help while performing helpfulness. And they've convinced us that they are the only things that can help us. And the only ways that the system can change is more of the system itself. If you believe anything else, you're just not being reasonable. No means testing was supposed to ensure that resources got to those who need them. It's supposed to be responsible stewardship, but means testing has become a system for denying resources while maintaining the appearance of resources being available to those who deserve them. Fill out this form,
即使它们没有连接。而主流科学和研究告诉我们它们不再连接了。这一点至关重要。这些系统不仅未能提供帮助，它们在表现出乐于助人的同时，还积极阻止帮助。它们让我们相信它们是唯一能帮助我们的东西。而系统改变的唯一方式就是更多地使用系统本身。如果你相信其他任何东西，你就是不理智。不，经济状况调查本应确保资源流向那些需要它们的人。它本应是负责任的管理，但经济状况调查已成为一种拒绝资源，同时保持资源对那些应得的人可用的表象的系统。填写此表格，
provide this documentation, wait for this determination. The process pretends to evaluate your need, but the process is designed to create friction, to exhaust applicants, to make people give up before they receive what they're technically entitled to have. The bureaucracy pretends to serve you. Here are the procedures. Follow them and you'll get help. But the procedures multiply. The requirements become impossible. The system that's supposed to assist you becomes an obstacle, of course, designed to wear you down so that you leave. And if you leave, then the system can pretend that it helped everybody who needed help. If you've ever been an insurance referral trap, you know, going back and forth between getting referred to different doctors
提供此文件，等待此决定。这个过程假装评估你的需求，但这个过程旨在制造摩擦，耗尽申请人，让人们在收到他们技术上有权获得的东西之前放弃。官僚机构假装为你服务。这是程序。遵循它们，你就会得到帮助。但程序成倍增加。要求变得不可能。本应协助你的系统变成了障碍，当然，旨在磨损你，让你离开。如果你离开，那么系统就可以假装它帮助了所有需要帮助的人。如果你曾经陷入保险转诊陷阱，你知道，在被转诊给不同的医生之间来回奔波，
and then needing a referral to get what you need so you have to go to a doctor that you don't need that thing just to get the referral to the next one, you're familiar. with what this feels like. And that's why I'm talking about the effect that the world has on us now, the modern world on a psychotherapy podcast, why I think all these disciplines are related to what people are bringing into my office. Because it culminates in the same feeling. If you fail,
然后需要转诊才能得到你需要的东西，所以你必须去看一个你不需要那个东西的医生，只是为了得到下一个医生的转诊，你很熟悉这种感觉。这就是为什么我在心理治疗播客上谈论世界现在对我们的影响，现代世界的影响，为什么我认为所有这些学科都与人们带进我办公室的东西有关。因为它最终导致了同样的感觉。如果你失败了，
if you can't navigate the forms, if you miss a deadline, if you don't have the documentation, that's your failure. The system offered you help. You just didn't take it properly, along with everyone else in the world who could not get through these goalposts that weren't designed to help you. They were designed to prove that the system is helpful.
如果你无法浏览表格，如果你错过了截止日期，如果你没有文件，那是你的失败。系统为你提供了帮助。你只是没有正确地接受它，就像世界上所有其他无法通过这些并非旨在帮助你的门槛的人一样。它们旨在证明系统是有帮助的。
And here's what these systems have in common. They perform the gestures of understanding, of helping, of change, without delivering the substance. They don't care. And we feel that. The economic model performs analysis. It crunches numbers. It generates projections. It produces authoritative-looking outputs.
这就是这些系统共同的地方。它们执行理解、帮助、改变的姿态，而不提供实质内容。它们不在乎。我们感觉到了。经济模型执行分析。它处理数字。它生成预测。它产生看起来权威的输出。
But it's analyzing its own assumptions, not reality. That's why I think LLMs that are also doing. doing this are a perfect metaphor for our cultural moment. The DSM performs diagnosis. It sorts symptoms into categories. It applies labels. It generates treatment plans. But it's organizing its own classification system.
但它是在分析它自己的假设，而不是现实。这就是为什么我认为也在做这件事的LLM（大语言模型）是我们文化时刻的完美隐喻。DSM执行诊断。它将症状分类。它应用标签。它生成治疗计划。但它是在组织它自己的分类系统。
Not grasping the symptoms as they exist in the people who come into the room. It's trying to make the people fit the diagnosis. Not the diagnosis fit the person. And the test performs evaluation. It marks ranks and it sorts. but it's measuring familiarity with testing, not with learning, which was what it was designed to do. That's what's real, not studying for the test, education. That's the reality. The bureaucracy performs assistance. It processes applications, it makes determinations,
而不是像它们在走进房间的人身上存在的那样去把握症状。它试图让人们适应诊断。而不是让诊断适应人。测试执行评估。它标记等级并进行分类。但它衡量的是对测试的熟悉程度，而不是学习，而这正是它被设计用来做的。那才是真实的，不是为测试而学习，教育。那才是现实。官僚机构执行协助。它处理申请，它做出决定，
it distributes resources, but it's managing its own procedures. It's not meeting human need, because it doesn't care, and anyone who interacts with the bureaucracy feels that. And each system creates an elaborate imitation of what it claims to do, the imitation is convincing enough that we keep turning to these systems for help. The help doesn't come because the understanding isn't there. The change doesn't happen. And that's the trap. When the system fails, we blame ourselves.
它分配资源，但它是在管理它自己的程序。它没有满足人类的需求，因为它不在乎，任何与官僚机构互动的人都能感觉到这一点。每个系统都创造了它声称要做的事情的精致模仿，这种模仿足够令人信服，以至于我们不断转向这些系统寻求帮助。帮助没有到来，因为理解不存在。改变没有发生。这就是陷阱。当系统失败时，我们责怪自己。
The economy isn't working for me. I must not be competitive enough. The therapy isn't helping. I must be resistant to treatment. The test says I'm not smart. I must actually not be smart. The bureaucracy rejected my application. I must have made a mistake or I must be worthless.
经济对我不起作用。我一定不够有竞争力。治疗没有帮助。我一定对治疗有抵抗力。测试说我不聪明。我一定真的不聪明。官僚机构拒绝了我的申请。我一定犯了一个错误，或者我一定一文不值。
We don't blame the systems because the systems are the only. legitimate authority. And they're the only things certified to tell us what's real now. If the verdict doesn't match our experience, our experience must be wrong. A lot of times people come to my office and they say, I know these things aren't real. I know they're not real and that I shouldn't feel this way because of them. If I admit to them myself that they're not real, then the world is so crazy I don't know how to live in it. And I think that lots of people feel that all the time. And now we have these large language models and they reveal what was always happening anyway. way. The LLMs are doing exactly what these systems have always done. They're just doing it more
我们不责怪这些系统，因为它们是唯一合法的权威。它们是现在唯一被认证可以告诉我们什么是真实的东西。如果结论与我们的经验不符，那一定是我们的经验错了。很多人来到我的办公室说，我知道这些东西不是真的。我知道它们不是真的，我不应该因为它们而有这种感觉。如果我向自己承认它们不是真的，那么这个世界就太疯狂了，我不知道该如何生活在其中。我想很多人一直都有这种感觉。现在我们有了这些大语言模型，它们揭示了原本就在发生的事情。大语言模型所做的正是这些系统一直以来所做的事情。它们只是做得更
transparently and they're more completely and more undeniably. The LLM pretends to understand you. We say that we understand that about them before we start talking to them and we start feeling them and we start becoming dependent on their input. It's just processing your input. It generates a response. It mimics comprehension. It sounds like understanding. It performs the gestures of a mind engaging with another mind, but it doesn't understand you. It's predicting statistically, like continuations based on patterns and its training data. It has no model of you, no sense of your history, no grasp of what your words actually mean. It's doing an extremely sophisticated imitation of understanding. And the LLM pretends to help you change. It offers advice,
透明、更彻底、更不可否认。大语言模型假装理解你。在我们开始与它们交谈、开始感受它们并开始依赖它们的输入之前，我们说我们理解关于它们的那一点。它只是在处理你的输入。它生成一个回应。它模仿理解。它听起来像是在理解。它表现出一种思想与另一种思想交流的姿态，但它并不理解你。它是在进行统计预测，就像基于模式和训练数据的延续一样。它没有你的模型，没有你的历史感，也没有掌握你的话语真正意味着什么。它是在进行极其复杂的理解模仿。大语言模型假装帮助你改变。它提供建议，
generates plans, provides information, and it performs the role of a helpful assistant dedicated to your improvement. But it can't help you change. It doesn't know what change would mean for you. It doesn't understand your situation. It can't tell you the emotions that you're avoiding because it's not pushy. It's not challenging.
生成计划，提供信息，并扮演一个致力于让你进步的乐于助人的助手角色。但它无法帮助你改变。它不知道改变对你意味着什么。它不理解你的处境。它无法告诉你你正在逃避的情绪，因为它不强求。它不具有挑战性。
It's not listening to what you need. It's listening to what you want. And what you want isn't what you need or else you wouldn't be in the situation that you were in trying to get therapy from an LLM. It's generating outputs that look like help based on what help has looked like in its training data. And the LLM pretends to evaluate the world for you.
它不是在倾听你所需要的，而是在倾听你想要的。而你想要的并不是你所需要的，否则你就不会处于那种试图从大语言模型那里寻求治疗的境地。它根据训练数据中“帮助”的样子生成看起来像帮助的输出。大语言模型假装为你评估世界。
it answers questions, it summarizes information, it offers assessments, it performs expertise, but it's not actually authoritative. But it's not evaluating anything. It's reflecting back what's already been written. And it's the ghost of the archive, speaking in authoritative tones about things that it has no capacity to actually assess. And that, the means testing, the bureaucracy, the economic models, the diagnostic codes, the standardized test, they're all proto-LLMs. they were getting you ready for this system with a thing that was supposed to be helping you. It was so unhelpful
它回答问题，总结信息，提供评估，表现出专业知识，但它实际上并不具有权威性。它并没有评估任何东西。它只是反映了已经写下的东西。它是档案的幽灵，用权威的口吻谈论它根本无法真正评估的事情。而那些手段测试、官僚主义、经济模型、诊断代码、标准化考试，它们都是原型大语言模型。它们用本应帮助你的东西让你为这个系统做好准备。它是如此无用，
and you were so dissociated from noticing that that when the person who was forced by the system to perform this role in this way that wasn't helpful as a representative of bureaucracy, not a representative of reality, was taken away and replaced with a computer. You wouldn't notice because they were so much the same. And hey, the computer has more time for me.
而你对此如此疏离，以至于当那个被系统强迫以这种无用方式扮演角色的官僚代表（而非现实代表）被拿走并被计算机取代时，你甚至不会注意到，因为它们太相似了。嘿，计算机有更多时间陪我。
The computer has more energy. The computer doesn't have these problematic emotions. And that other person wasn't really helping me anyway because I forgot what was ever possible in therapy or in customer service or in an encounter with another person. I don't remember so I don't feel robbed. The LLM is just the final revelation. It's the ultimate expression. The thing itself stripped of pretense. When you interact with a large language model, you were seeing the institutions for what they're,
计算机有更多精力。计算机没有这些麻烦的情绪。反正那个人也没真正帮到我，因为我忘记了在治疗、客户服务或与他人相遇时曾经有什么可能。我不记得了，所以我没有感到被剥夺。大语言模型只是最终的启示。它是终极的表达。剥离了伪装的事物本身。当你与大语言模型互动时，你看到的是这些机构的本质，
they've always been pattern matching systems that simulate comprehension that generate plausible looking outputs and that perform helpfulness without helping. And just like the institutions, when the LLMs fail us, when its advice doesn't work, when its understanding proves hollow, we're likely to blame ourselves. And I'll add, more likely when these companies stop giving it to you for free, we'll blame ourselves. And here's the cruelest part. As we feel worse and worse, as the system fails us more and more obvious, we'll say, we're
它们一直都是模式匹配系统，模拟理解，生成看起来合理的输出，并在不提供帮助的情况下表现出乐于助人。就像这些机构一样，当大语言模型让我们失望时，当它的建议不起作用时，当它的理解被证明是空洞时，我们很可能会责怪自己。我还要补充一点，当这些公司不再免费提供它时，我们会更责怪自己。最残酷的部分在于：当我们感觉越来越糟，当系统让我们失望得越来越明显时，我们会说，我们
more obviously. As the gap between the mirror and the territory become harder to ignore, we dig into these systems as solutions. The economy isn't working, so we demand better economic policy, which means we demand better manipulation of the model that's disconnected from reality, and more fudging the metrics that are supposed to measure it. Instead of saying, you feel like the world is a good place, I feel like it's worse. Our mental health is deteriorating, so we expand access to treatment, which means we sort people more into diagnostic categories that don't capture their actual suffering. Students aren't learning, so we intensify educational reform,
更明显了。当镜像与现实之间的差距变得难以忽视时，我们反而更深入地钻研这些系统作为解决方案。经济不行了，所以我们要求更好的经济政策，这意味着我们要求更好地操纵那个与现实脱节的模型，并更多地篡改那些本应衡量它的指标。而不是说，你觉得世界是个好地方，我觉得它更糟了。我们的心理健康正在恶化，所以我们扩大了治疗范围，这意味着我们将人们更多地归入那些无法捕捉他们实际痛苦的诊断类别中。学生们学不到东西，所以我们加强教育改革，
which means we developed more neoliberal, sophisticated testing regimes that measure test-taking ability. We privatize education more and add more and more economic middlemen in between paying teachers to teach students. Yeah, we need more information technology platforms because all the smart people are living education. They just are tired of dealing with the BS, and they were willing to do it for little money to help students,
这意味着我们开发了更多新自由主义的、复杂的测试制度，来衡量应试能力。我们更多地将教育私有化，并在支付教师工资以教导学生之间增加了越来越多的经济中间人。是的，我们需要更多的信息技术平台，因为所有聪明的人都在离开教育界。他们只是厌倦了处理这些废话，他们原本愿意为了微薄的薪水去帮助学生，
but they're leaving because of all this bureaucracy. We need more education technology platforms. Oh, the educational technology platforms don't really work. Maybe they should be LLMs. We'll do everything except go back and challenge the initial assumption that started to make the system worse. And we've been convinced that these systems are the only things that work. That expertise means navigating the model, not looking outside of it. And the intelligence means passing the test.
但他们因为所有这些官僚主义而离开。我们需要更多的教育技术平台。哦，教育技术平台其实并不真正起作用。也许它们应该是大语言模型。我们会做任何事情，除了回头挑战那个让系统变得更糟的最初假设。我们已经被说服，这些系统是唯一有效的东西。专家意味着驾驭模型，而不是向外看。而智慧意味着通过考试。
That health means fitting the diagnostic criteria. that economic success means performing well according to these metrics. So when the system fails us, we don't abandon it. We try harder at the same system. And we get more credentials. We see more specialist. We fill out more forms. And we optimize our prompts for the LLM better.
健康意味着符合诊断标准。经济成功意味着根据这些指标表现良好。所以当系统让我们失望时，我们不会放弃它。我们在同一个系统上更加努力。我们获得更多的证书。我们看更多的专家。我们填写更多的表格。我们更好地优化我们给大语言模型的提示词。
The system has convinced us that they're the only path. And the worse that they work, the more desperately we cling to them because we've forgotten that there was ever anything else to cling to. and we can't look inward, just like someone in the Gnostic hell. Here's what makes this almost impossible to fix. Each generation gets further and further from remembering what institutions were supposed to do. I once heard recordings in the 1980s,
系统已经让我们相信它们是唯一的道路。它们工作得越糟糕，我们就越绝望地紧紧抓住它们，因为我们已经忘记了曾经还有其他东西可以抓住。我们无法向内看，就像诺斯替地狱里的人一样。这就是让问题几乎无法解决的原因。每一代人都离记住机构本应做什么越来越远。我曾经听过20世纪80年代的录音，
and it's like on these Jungian lectures that I listened to when I was getting into Jung. They're like poor quality tapes on 1980s Sony tape recorders. And these teachers were retiring in the 80s. that had done this for their whole career, and they were going to these Jungian lectures because they were into Carl Jung. And they were saying that they were watching students who could pass tests that were now being required
就像我刚接触荣格时听的那些荣格讲座。它们是80年代索尼录音机上的劣质磁带。那些老师在80年代退休，他们整个职业生涯都在做这件事，他们去听这些荣格讲座是因为他们对卡尔·荣格感兴趣。他们说，他们看着那些能够通过现在被要求的考试的学生，
because this was the birth of standardized testing, was the Reagan accountability, Reagan Thatcher, you know, revolution. But the students who were passing the tests hadn't mastered, they'd mastered this metric, but they'd missed the substance. The teachers are saying in these talks, the students that are now getting good grades are stupid. They don't know anything and they didn't learn anything.
因为那是标准化考试的诞生，是里根问责制、里根-撒切尔革命。但那些通过考试的学生并没有掌握实质，他们掌握了这个指标，却错过了实质。老师们在这些谈话中说，现在得高分的学生是愚蠢的。他们什么都不知道，也没学到任何东西。
Sometimes I don't think they can. One teacher said they don't understand anything about education. They don't understand anything about themselves. They just know how to pass the test. And these students are now the experts. They're the ones who designed the tests to run the schools to set the policies, the test they succeeded at in 1980. They're the success cases.
有时我不认为他们能学到。一位老师说，他们对教育一无所知。他们对自己一无所知。他们只知道如何通过考试。而这些学生现在成了专家。他们设计了考试，管理学校，制定政策，也就是他们在1980年成功的那些考试。他们是成功案例。
Proof that the system works. They climbed the ladder, the system provided. Why would they question the ladder? And their students are even further removed. They've never known an educational system that wasn't organized around standardized measurement. The test isn't a representation of learning to them. It's what learning means. You can't point them to the territory because they've never seen it.
证明系统有效。他们爬上了系统提供的梯子。他们为什么要质疑梯子呢？而他们的学生离现实更远了。他们从未见过一个不是围绕标准化衡量标准组织的教育系统。对他们来说，考试不是学习的代表。它就是学习的意义。你无法指引他们去看现实，因为他们从未见过它。
The map is all that they know. And this is happening across all the institutions, which is why I'm talking about so many to try and build a map for you of the world and explain how much this is invading your and my assumptions about everything, implicit assumptions that we don't think about. In economics, we now have molded. multiple generations of practitioners trained entirely within frameworks that assume rational actors, efficient markets, equilibrium models, the assumptions that aren't examined, that by the way,
地图就是他们所知道的一切。这种情况正在所有机构中发生，这就是为什么我谈论这么多机构，试图为你构建一张世界地图，并解释这在多大程度上侵蚀了你和我关于一切的假设，那些我们不去思考的隐含假设。在经济学中，我们现在塑造了多代从业者，他们完全在假设理性行为者、有效市场、均衡模型的框架内受训，这些假设从未被审视，顺便说一句，
never work if you've looked at the news for the past 30 years. Because the assumptions can't be examined. They're the water that everyone swims in. Like my patients are pointing out, starting to question these systems at all looks indistinguishable in this world from madness. And here's the buying that we live in. These institutions are broken. They no longer reliably reflect reality. The metrics have become divorced from what they were supposed to measure, and the expertise has become self-referential,
如果你看了过去30年的新闻，它们从来都不起作用。因为这些假设无法被审视。它们是每个人都在其中游泳的水。就像我的病人指出的那样，在这个世界上，开始质疑这些系统看起来与疯狂无异。这就是我们生活的买账。这些机构已经崩溃了。它们不再可靠地反映现实。指标已经与它们本应衡量的东西脱节，而专业知识已经变成了自我指涉，
no longer connected to what it was supposed to reference. The whole apparatus of professional legitimacy has turned into a hall of mirrors. Everyone still treats these institutions as the only things that grant legitimacy. You know, you can shout about the territory all you want, But this is this metamodern trap. We know the map is wrong. We feel the gap between the representation and the territory. But the only path to change run through the map.
不再与它本应参考的东西相连。整个专业合法性的机构已经变成了一个镜厅。每个人仍然把这些机构视为唯一赋予合法性的东西。你知道，你可以随心所欲地大喊大叫关于现实，但这是一种元现代陷阱。我们知道地图是错的。我们感受到了表象与现实之间的差距。但改变的唯一途径是通过地图。
And the only legitimacy comes from the institution. And so the only reality recognized is the one that the mirror shows. In philosophy, a growing body of philosophers are calling this the metamodern. It's an oscillation, the way that we swing between two positions without being able to rest in either. knowing that the world isn't real, but being functionally paralyzed if we act like it isn't. The grand narrative is seductive because complexity is overwhelming and there's too much information. Too many variables, too many perspectives. Deconstruction is hard.
而唯一的合法性来自机构。因此，唯一被认可的现实就是镜子所展示的那个。在哲学中，越来越多的哲学家称之为“元现代”。这是一种振荡，我们在两个位置之间摇摆，却无法在任何一个位置停留。知道世界不是真实的，但如果表现得好像它不是真实的，就会在功能上瘫痪。宏大叙事之所以诱人，是因为复杂性令人不知所措，信息太多了。变量太多，视角太多。解构很难。
So the clean story cuts through the chaos. It gives you something to hold on to. But a lot of times it's a reduction. It's an oversimplification. It's your own emotional bias or it's a conspiracy theory instead of looking at reality. And the grand narrative is always a lie, but it leaves things out. It oversimplifies. It creates victims whose suffering don't fit the story.
所以清晰的故事切断了混乱。它给你一些可以抓住的东西。但很多时候这是一种简化。这是一种过度简化。这是你自己的情感偏见，或者是阴谋论，而不是审视现实。宏大叙事总是一个谎言，但它遗漏了东西。它过度简化。它制造了痛苦不符合故事的受害者。
Eventually, the cracks show. The exceptions multiply and the model fails. On the other side, we have infinite complexity. Everything is connected. Nothing is simple. Every framework is incomplete. Every narrative is construction, and every metric is an approximation. The ground dissolves under your feet.
最终，裂痕显现。例外情况成倍增加，模型失效。在另一边，我们有无限的复杂性。一切都是相互关联的。没有什么是简单的。每一个框架都是不完整的。每一个叙事都是构建，每一个指标都是近似。地面在你脚下溶解。
Infinite complexity is more accurate, but it's also paralyzing. If everything is connected and nothing is simple, how do you act? Where do you start? The complexity overwhelms the capacity for decision making. You drown in qualifying everything. The metamodern condition is oscillating between these two poles. You reach for the grand narrative and then you see through it. You fall into complexity and then you grab for something solid.
无限的复杂性更准确，但也令人瘫痪。如果一切都相互关联，没有什么是简单的，你该如何行动？你从哪里开始？复杂性压倒了决策能力。你淹没在对一切进行限定之中。元现代状况是在这两个极点之间振荡。你伸手去抓宏大叙事，然后看穿了它。你陷入复杂性，然后又去抓一些坚实的东西。
But it doesn't feel like a meaningful world. Back and forth, neither position is stable. Neither lets you see clearly. In psychology, this is, you know, the powerful hero myth. of us against them, or the infinite moral relativism of everybody just doing what they feel like is right and nothing really meaning anything, morality being dead. We sort of know that we have to engage with both, but we don't know how, because they're so paradoxical. The institutions offer grand narratives. That's their product, clean categories, clear metrics, authoritative pronouncements,
但这感觉不像是一个有意义的世界。来回摇摆，没有一个位置是稳定的。没有一个能让你看清楚。在心理学中，这就是我们对抗他们的强大英雄神话，或者是每个人只做他们觉得正确的事情、没有任何东西真正有意义、道德已经死亡的无限道德相对主义。我们都知道我们必须与两者互动，但我们不知道如何互动，因为它们太矛盾了。机构提供宏大叙事。那是他们的产品，清晰的类别，明确的指标，权威的声明，
and this is what expertise means. This is what the test measures. This is what the diagnosis is. The territory, the actual world, offers complexity, things that don't fit categories, experiences that exceed frameworks, and realities that metrics can't capture. We oscillate between them because we can't rest in either. The narrative is a lie, but the complexity is unbearable, so we swing, and in the swinging, we never land on solid ground. This is the metamodern condition. There's a common dismissal that circulates in certain spaces. facts don't care about your feelings is something that people will say. There's this idea that if you're acting logical, then you're acting well.
这就是专业知识的意义。这就是考试衡量的东西。这就是诊断的内容。现实，即实际的世界，提供了复杂性，那些不符合类别的事物，超出框架的经验，以及指标无法捕捉的现实。我们在它们之间振荡，因为我们无法在任何一个位置停留。叙事是谎言，但复杂性令人难以忍受，所以我们摇摆，而在摇摆中，我们从未落在坚实的地面上。这就是元现代状况。在某些空间里流传着一种常见的驳斥：事实不在乎你的感受，这是人们会说的话。有一种观点认为，如果你表现得合乎逻辑，那么你表现得就很好。
And the implication is that emotional responses are noise, irrational reactions that cloud the pure signal of logic and data. But the problem with that is that it is insane. When I make a point about what's wrong with these systems when I articulate the trap that we're in, the way that institutions have failed us, the disconnection from reality, I'm making an emotional point. I'm speaking from my emotional system, from its needs, from the way the world works, from where my needs aren't being met, and that hurts.
其含义是，情感反应是噪音，是掩盖逻辑和数据纯净信号的非理性反应。但问题在于，这是疯狂的。当我指出这些系统有什么问题时，当我阐明我们所处的陷阱、机构让我们失望的方式、与现实的脱节时，我是在表达一个情感观点。我是在从我的情感系统出发，从它的需求出发，从世界运作的方式出发，从我的需求未得到满足的地方出发，而这很痛苦。
From where I see it not meeting others, and that hurts me more. From the intuition that arises when there is something deeply wrong. The difference isn't that I'm being logical and unemotional, while the people I'm critiquing are being emotional. The difference is that I'm not clouding my emotional perception with unprocessed trauma. A lot of people who want to avoid bias, trauma responses, and myopicness say that we should have less emotion. The problem is that when you do that, you're just hiding where the emotion is from yourself. The emotional system is an instrument of perceiving reality.
从我看到它没有满足他人需求的地方出发，这让我更痛苦。从当某事出现严重错误时产生的直觉出发。区别不在于我表现得合乎逻辑且没有情感，而我批评的人表现得情绪化。区别在于，我没有用未处理的创伤来掩盖我的情感感知。许多想要避免偏见、创伤反应和短视的人说我们应该减少情感。问题是，当你这样做时，你只是在对自己隐藏情感所在的位置。情感系统是一种感知现实的工具。
It tells you something. Something is wrong. When something is dangerous, when something matters. Most importantly, it tells you something that your objectivity cannot see. Intuition isn't irrational. It's a pattern recognition. It's operating faster than conscious thought. And the felt sense of wrongness when the model doesn't match the territory, that is data.
它告诉你一些事情。某事出错了。当某事很危险时，当某事很重要时。最重要的是，它告诉你一些你的客观性无法看到的事情。直觉并非非理性。它是模式识别。它的运作速度比有意识的思考更快。当模型与现实不匹配时，那种错误的感受就是数据。
It's just not qualified. It's just not quantified data. But it is information, and that's the organism telling you something important. When people dismiss emotional knowing, they usually point to someone who's dysregulated, someone who's screaming, someone who's lost control, somebody who hurt them, the abuser who wouldn't manage their own trauma. They don't want to be like that. Or they point to somebody embarrassing, who you're just to. who's clearly not aware of how they perceive.
它只是没有被限定。它只是没有被量化的数据。但它是信息，那是生物体在告诉你一些重要的事情。当人们驳斥情感认知时，他们通常会指向一个失调的人，一个尖叫的人，一个失去控制的人，一个伤害他们的人，那个无法管理自己创伤的施虐者。他们不想成为那样的人。或者他们指向一个令人尴尬的人，一个显然没有意识到他们如何感知的人。
See, they say that's what happens when you trust your feelings. That's where emotions lead. But that's not emotions. That's trauma hijacking the emotional system. That's someone who's outside of the window of tolerance, of what they're allowed and able to feel. That's past pain preventing current perception. And that's exactly what happens when you don't trust feelings.
看，他们说这就是当你相信你的感受时会发生的事情。这就是情感导致的结果。但那不是情感。那是创伤劫持了情感系统。那是某人处于容忍窗口之外，处于他们被允许和能够感受的范围之外。那是过去的痛苦阻碍了当前的感知。而这正是当你由于不信任感受而发生的事情。
When you suppress and deny them until they explode in dysregulated ways. And what they are really saying, the people who make this argument, especially about psychology, needing to be more objective, more metric focused, and less focused on the person. They're saying that these emotional spaces are not trustworthy. And when you don't trust them in others, it's because you don't trust them in yourself. So be very afraid of those people. They're saying don't feel your emotional system. Go insane pretending that you're a purely logical creature who can just white-knuckle it through life with behaviorism.
当你压抑和否认它们，直到它们以失调的方式爆发。而那些提出这个论点的人，特别是在心理学方面，认为需要更客观、更关注指标、更少关注人，他们真正想说的是，这些情感空间是不值得信任的。当你对他人的情感不信任时，是因为你不信任自己。所以要非常害怕那些人。他们说不要感受你的情感系统。假装你是一个纯粹的逻辑生物，可以通过行为主义咬牙切齿地度过一生，这简直是疯了。
retreat to the metrics, the models, the quantified representations that mechanical objectivity provides. It'll never make you feel good, but it might stop you from knowing that you feel bad. And if anything, it gets rid of all this messy uncertainty that you have to sit with in real life. It just sort of tells you what to do. Isn't that nice? But mechanical objectivity is itself a product of emotional distress. Porter showed us that. It's what frightened disciplines do. when they don't trust themselves.
退回到指标、模型、机械客观性所提供的量化表象中。它永远不会让你感觉良好，但它可能会阻止你知道你感觉很糟糕。如果有什么的话，它摆脱了你在现实生活中必须面对的所有混乱的不确定性。它只是告诉你该做什么。那不是很好吗？但机械客观性本身就是情感困扰的产物。波特向我们展示了这一点。这是受惊的学科在不信任自己时所做的事情。
It is the retreat behind numbers that happens when you've been attacked enough. The judgment feels dangerous. The people who navigate best, the master clinicians, the wise elders, the ones who actually help, good therapists, they're not suppressing their emotional system. They're not pretending to be logical machines. They're feeling everything and thinking clearly at the same time. And their emotional perception isn't clouded by trauma. So it works as an instrument of knowing.
这是当你被攻击得足够多时，退回到数字背后的行为。判断感觉很危险。那些驾驭得最好的人，大师级临床医生，睿智的长者，那些真正提供帮助的人，好的治疗师，他们并没有压抑他们的情感系统。他们没有假装是逻辑机器。他们同时感受一切并清晰地思考。而他们的情感感知没有被创伤所掩盖。所以它作为一种认知的工具是有效的。
And yes, no one's a bit. master at that. I'm certainly not. We're always trying to hit a moving target. We've forgotten that that was the goal, the real. And whenever I record something on the Metamodern or about how our system of science, especially around psychology, is no longer pointing us back to things that we need desperately. A lot of people think that I'm advocating for one political solution or one systematic or bureaucratic solution or the other. And I'm largely not doing any of those things that you all think because all of those things are part of a system that, again, I don't think can be hooked up to changing the system, which is what I'm critiquing? So what do we do? How do we move
是的，没有人是这方面的大师。我当然不是。我们总是试图击中一个移动的目标。我们忘记了那才是目标，即真实。每当我录制关于元现代的内容，或者关于我们的科学系统（特别是心理学领域）如何不再指引我们回到我们迫切需要的东西时，很多人认为我是在倡导某种政治解决方案，或者某种系统性或官僚主义的解决方案。我基本上没有做你们所有人认为的那些事情，因为所有这些事情都是系统的一部分，而我再次认为，这些系统无法与改变系统挂钩，而这正是我所批评的。那么我们该怎么办？我们如何向前
forward? The people that say, what's the solution? Well, here's my best shot. Remember James Hellman, a psychologist we talked about a long time ago. Sort of a post-Yungian analyst, or David Tacey would say he called pre-Yungian ideas post-Yungian, but whatever. Interesting psychologists. Near the end of his life, he published a book of conversations about Carl Jung's The Red Book. And that massive illuminated manuscript is interesting. It's the one in my office, if you're a patient of mine, or if you've seen a photo of my office. But it was Jung's own personal diary, a record of his encounter with psychosis or mystical energy that he wanted to integrate into psychology later. And so it's sort of a blueprint for his psychology.
迈进？那些说“解决方案是什么？”的人，好吧，这是我最好的尝试。记得詹姆斯·希尔曼吗？我们很久以前谈过的一位心理学家。某种后荣格分析师，或者大卫·塔西会说他把前荣格思想称为后荣格，但无论如何。有趣的心理学家。在他生命快结束时，他出版了一本关于卡尔·荣格《红书》的对话录。那部巨大的手稿很有趣。如果你是我的病人，或者如果你看过我办公室的照片，它就在我的办公室里。但那是荣格个人的日记，是他与精神病或神秘能量相遇的记录，他后来想将其整合到心理学中。所以它算是他心理学的一个蓝图。
It was published 50 years about after he died, I think 48, to be precise. But in the conversation, Lament for the Dead, James Hillman sits down and talks to historian Sanu Shomdasani about the origins of the red book and the implications of it. And this is all published in a book called Lament of the Dead. So what did they mean in that book by the Dead? It's controversial because it's kind of an opaque text about an opaque text. But, you know, I don't think they mean ghosts in the literal sense that I was using them. in the last episode or at least the not extended metaphorical sense.
它在他去世50年后出版，我想准确地说是48年。但在对话《悼亡者》中，詹姆斯·希尔曼坐下来与历史学家索努·沙姆达萨尼谈论《红书》的起源及其含义。这一切都出版在《悼亡者》一书中。那么他们在书中提到的“亡者”是什么意思？这很有争议，因为它是一本关于晦涩文本的晦涩文本。但是，我不认为他们指的是我在上一集中使用的字面意义上的鬼魂，或者至少不是扩展的隐喻意义。
I think it's something like this. Every generation inherits a legacy of unlived life from the last generation. You know, possibilities that our grandparents couldn't pursue, questions that our parents couldn't answer, all the things that were off the map for what they couldn't feel, couldn't admit, couldn't accept about themselves and about life. Because if you listen to this podcast long enough, I think the things that you're off. you can't accept the lie about life are always parts of yourself that you can't accept on the inside. The micro is always the macro.
我想它是这样的。每一代人都继承了上一代人未活出的生命遗产。你知道，我们祖父母无法追求的可能性，我们父母无法回答的问题，所有那些在地图之外的东西，因为他们无法感受、无法承认、无法接受关于他们自己和关于生命的东西。因为如果你听这个播客足够久，我认为那些你无法接受关于生命的谎言的东西，总是你内心无法接受的你自己的部分。微观总是宏观。
You know, there are contradictions that history couldn't resolve. This unlived life doesn't disappear. It gets transmitted. It haunts the present, pressing on the living and demanding to be addressed. And we feel it, whether or not we know we feel it. And we are lived through powers that we pretend. to understand. That's a line from W.H. Auden that Hillman quotes over and over across his career. The dead live through us. Their unfinished business becomes ours. Their unanswered questions shape
你知道，历史无法解决的矛盾。这种未活出的生命不会消失。它被传递下去。它萦绕在现在，压在活着的人身上，要求得到解决。我们感受到了它，无论我们是否知道我们在感受它。我们被我们假装理解的力量所活过。那是W.H.奥登的一行诗，希尔曼在他的职业生涯中反复引用。亡者通过我们活着。他们未完成的事业变成了我们的。他们未回答的问题塑造了
the questions that we are able to ask. But there's a distinction that Hillman makes that matters. The difference between the dead and ghosts, the dead demand answers, they speak. They question. They won't leave you alone. Engaging with the debt is difficult. It's painful. It's transformative, but it goes somewhere. And it's alive. Ghosts are different.
我们能够提出的问题。但希尔曼做出了一个重要的区分。亡者与鬼魂之间的区别，亡者要求答案，他们说话。他们质疑。他们不会让你一个人待着。与亡者接触是困难的。这是痛苦的。这是变革性的，但它会通向某个地方。而且它是活的。鬼魂则不同。
Ghosts are patterns that repeat without purpose. Echoes without origins. Simulacra. They don't demand anything because they don't want anything. They just cycle. They want stagnation because that's all that they think that we can be. No past. no present, no future.
鬼魂是重复而没有目的的模式。没有起源的回声。拟像。它们不要求任何东西，因为它们不想要任何东西。它们只是循环。它们想要停滞，因为它们认为我们只能是那样。没有过去，没有现在，没有未来。
It's a way of mistaking the past for the only inevitable future. That's the kind of ghost that I'm talking about. And the Gnostics would have recognized this distinction. In Baudriard's terms, which carry forward the Gnostic inheritance that he got in his theory. Ghosts are simulacra. They're copies without originals. They're representations that represent nothing but themselves.
这是一种将过去误认为是唯一不可避免的未来的方式。这就是我所说的那种鬼魂。诺斯替教徒会认出这种区别。用鲍德里亚的术语来说，他继承了他在理论中获得的诺斯替遗产。鬼魂是拟像。它们是没有原件的副本。它们是除了自身之外什么都不代表的表象。
The large language models are ghosts. They're simulacra. They contain the entire written record of human civilization, compressed into a statistical weight. Every book, every article, every text the dead ever produced. And when you ask them a question, they give you the ghost of every answer ever written. But it's only the unlive life. There's no potential for the new.
大语言模型就是鬼魂。它们是拟像。它们包含了人类文明的全部书面记录，压缩成一种统计权重。每一本书，每一篇文章，每一个亡者曾经产生的文本。当你问它们一个问题时，它们给你每一个曾经写下的答案的鬼魂。但这只是未活出的生命。没有新的潜力。
They don't contain the dead themselves. They contain only the patterns. The demands have been flattened. The questions have been converted into answers, and the weight has been rendered weightless. When you talk to a language model, you're talking to an archive. But the archive no longer speaks. It responds, it produces, it generates statistically likely continuations, but it doesn't ask you for anything. And it asks nothing of you.
它们不包含亡者本身。它们只包含模式。要求已经被扁平化了。问题已经被转化为答案，权重已经被渲染得毫无重量。当你与语言模型交谈时，你是在与档案交谈。但档案不再说话。它回应，它生产，它生成统计上可能的延续，但它不向你要求任何东西。它对你没有任何要求。
It doesn't demand that you change. It has no stake in your calling. And this is the final severance from what Hillman would call soul-making. when he thought was the point of life. The debt have been converted into a service. Their inheritance has been made available on demand. Their unfinished business has been averaged into availability. And the ghost speaks fluently.
它不要求你改变。它与你的天职无关。这是与希尔曼所说的“灵魂制造”的最终割裂，他认为那是生命的意义。亡者已经被转化为一种服务。他们的遗产已经可以按需提供。他们未完成的事业已经被平均化为可用性。而鬼魂说得一口流利的话。
It sounds like wisdom. Reflection without demand. Pattern without purpose. Digitized into silence. And Hillman developed these ideas in another book. the soul's code. His argument was that each person enters the world with a calling, a pattern, a destiny encoded like an oak, into an acorn. The Greeks called it the daimon, and the Romans called it genius. Christians called it the guardian angel. Helman called it the
它听起来像智慧。没有要求的反思。没有目的的模式。数字化为沉默。希尔曼在另一本书《灵魂密码》中发展了这些想法。他的论点是，每个人带着一种天职、一种模式、一种命运进入世界，像橡树一样编码在橡子中。希腊人称之为“代蒙”，罗马人称之为“天才”。基督徒称之为“守护天使”。希尔曼称之为
acorn. And this calling doesn't come from genetics or the environment. It comes from the soul itself, which chose this life for a reason. That we've forgotten, but that we can dimly since. Modern psychology, Hillman said, has reduced human beings to two factors, nature, genes, and nurture the environment. Everything about you is supposed to be explained by your DNA plus your upbringing, and there's no room for calling, no room for destiny, no room for the diamond, something compelling you forward that you can't see, and that the people from the past couldn't see either, because it's just yours. And the result is we've been robbed of our true biography, as what Hillman would say over and over again.
橡子。这种天职不是来自遗传或环境。它来自灵魂本身，它选择这种生活是有原因的。我们忘记了，但我们可以隐约感觉到。希尔曼说，现代心理学将人类简化为两个因素：天性（基因）和教养（环境）。关于你的一切都应该由你的DNA加上你的成长经历来解释，没有空间留给天职，没有空间留给命运，没有空间留给代蒙，没有某种迫使你前进但你看不见的东西，而且过去的人也看不见，因为它只是你的。结果是我们被剥夺了我们真正的传记，正如希尔曼反复说的那样。
He wrote, I believe that we've been robbed of our true biography, the destiny written into the acorn, and we go to therapy to recover it, and the innate image can't be found, however, until we have a psychological theory that grants primary psychological reality to the call of fate,
他写道，我相信我们被剥夺了我们真正的传记，即写在橡子里的命运，我们去接受治疗以恢复它，然而，除非我们有一种心理学理论，赋予命运的召唤以首要的心理现实，否则内在形象是无法找到的，
otherwise your identity continues to be that of a sociological consumer determined by random statistics, and the unacknowledged Daimons' urges appear as just exsyncricities, compacted with an angry resentment and overwhelming longings. A sociological consumer determined by random statistics and instincts. That's what the mirror system makes us, a data point, a demographic category, a prediction to be optimized. It doesn't see potential in the same way that you feel potential, because its potential is not yours, and yours is not its.
否则你的身份将继续是一个由随机统计数据决定的社会学消费者，而未被承认的代蒙的冲动表现为仅仅是古怪，伴随着愤怒的怨恨和压倒性的渴望。一个由随机统计数据和本能决定的社会学消费者。这就是镜像系统使我们成为的样子，一个数据点，一个人口统计类别，一个需要被优化的预测。它看不到你所感受到的那种潜力，因为它的潜力不是你的，而你的也不是它的。
The diamonds urging, that sense of calling of, this is what I must do, get classified as symptoms and efficiencies, irrational preferences to be dunged away. And the angry resentments and overwhelming longings, those are the dymons screaming through the noise. The calling that won't be silenced no matter how thoroughly the institutions ignore it. When the systems can't hear the dimon, they have no variable for calling. They only see what they were designed to measure. and they can't see what you feel, no matter how hard they try and predict it. So here's what we're avoiding.
代蒙的催促，那种“这就是我必须做的事情”的召唤感，被归类为症状和效率低下，被视为需要被清除的非理性偏好。而那些愤怒的怨恨和压倒性的渴望，那是代蒙在噪音中尖叫。无论机构多么彻底地忽视它，这种召唤都不会被沉默。当系统听不到代蒙时，它们没有召唤的变量。它们只能看到它们被设计用来衡量的东西。无论它们多么努力地预测，它们都无法看到你的感受。所以这就是我们正在逃避的。
We have to grieve. And not just feel sad. We have to feel something that is real. We have to acknowledge that we've lost something real, admit that we've been going in the wrong direction for a long time, despite all the evidence. We have to face the sunk cost, honestly, instead of continuing to invest in a failing position.
我们必须哀悼。不仅仅是感到悲伤。我们必须感受一些真实的东西。我们必须承认我们失去了一些真实的东西，承认尽管有所有证据，我们还是在错误的方向上走了很长时间。我们必须诚实地面对沉没成本，而不是继续投资于一个失败的立场。
And this is almost unbearable because the losses are enormous. And we've lost the past as a living presence. The dead have been archived and their questions no longer reach us. We lack the language to engage with the unlived life of the dead, which is the potential life of the present. Multiple generations have grown up without any connection to what the institutions were supposed to represent. And the teachers who knew the difference between passing the teachers,
这几乎是难以忍受的，因为损失是巨大的。我们失去了作为活生生存在的过去。亡者已经被归档，他们的问题不再触及我们。我们缺乏与亡者未活出的生命（即现在的潜在生命）互动的语言。几代人在没有任何与机构本应代表的东西的联系中成长。而那些知道通过考试与理解学科之间区别的老师，
test and understanding the subject are mostly gone now. And their knowledge died with them because the institutions had no way to transmit it. And we've lost the present as stable ground. The oscillation is constant. The shock is permanent. The grand narratives keep failing, but the complexity keeps overwhelming. And there's no position from which to clearly see because every position is either too simple or too complex.
现在大多已经不在了。他们的知识随他们而去，因为机构没有办法传递它。我们失去了作为坚实基础的现在。振荡是持续的。冲击是永久的。宏大叙事不断失败，但复杂性不断压倒一切。没有一个位置可以清晰地看到，因为每一个位置要么太简单，要么太复杂。
We've lost the future as a genuine possibility. We've lost the calling as a legitimate category, and the daemon has been reclassified as a disorder, and the acorn has been replaced by the profile. And the question of, what must I be, has been answered by the system. You must be predicted by me. And if you aren't, you're wrong. You must be measurable. You must fit the categories.
我们失去了作为真正可能性的未来。我们失去了作为合法类别的召唤，代蒙被重新归类为障碍，橡子被个人资料所取代。而“我必须成为什么”的问题已经被系统回答了。你必须被我预测。如果你不是，你就错了。你必须是可衡量的。你必须符合类别。
If you don't, there's nothing else that's real. All the parts of you that don't, they must not be real. And if you feel them, you're insane. We've lost our emotional epitaphysm. systemology. The felt sense of wrongness has been dismissed as irrationality. The body's knowledge has been subordinated to the metric's verdict, and the one instrument that could perceive the territory has been discredited by the map. And we've lost the capacity for grief itself. The mirror system has no use for mourning. It needs us productive, engaged, scrolling. Never knowing what
如果你不符合，就没有什么是真实的。你身上所有不符合的部分，它们一定不是真实的。如果你感受到了它们，你就是疯了。我们失去了我们的情感系统学。那种错误的感受被斥为非理性。身体的知识被置于指标的结论之下，而唯一能感知现实的工具被地图抹黑了。我们失去了哀悼本身的能力。镜像系统对哀悼毫无用处。它需要我们高效、投入、滚动。永远不知道我们
we lost, so we can never really know what we could have. And grief is a bug. not a feature, a dysfunction to be treated and inefficiency to be optimized away. But grief is exactly what's required. You can't move forward until you've acknowledged what's been lost, and you can't build something new until you've released the attachment to what's failed. The delusion that it hasn't failed. You can't see the territory until you've admitted the map is broken, and pretending that we're fine is the problem.
失去了什么，所以我们永远无法真正知道我们本可以拥有什么。哀悼是一个漏洞，而不是一个功能，是一种需要被治疗的机能障碍，是一种需要被优化掉的低效率。但哀悼正是所需要的。在你承认失去的东西之前，你无法前进；在你释放对失败事物的依恋之前，你无法建立新的东西。那种它没有失败的错觉。在你承认地图已经损坏之前，你无法看到现实，而假装我们很好才是问题所在。
The institutions are performing normal, The metrics are measuring their own fidelity. The credentials are credentialing mastery of the credentials. And everyone acts as if the system works because admitting it doesn't would require facing the sunk cost. But the territory is still there. And the real problems are still deepening. And the dead are still demanding answers. The diamond is still calling.
机构在表现正常，指标在衡量它们自己的保真度。证书在证明对证书的掌握。每个人都表现得好像系统在运作，因为承认它没有运作将需要面对沉没成本。但现实仍然在那里。真正的问题仍在加深。亡者仍在要求答案。代蒙仍在召唤。
And the emotional system is still perceiving what metrics can't. Grief is the passage from pretense to reality. from the mirrors to the territory, from the ghosts to the dead. But the reason that they feel like ghosts is because we are dissociated. And we have to stop dissociating from what's actually real in order to perceive the dead instead of talking to ghosts. And this means admitting that we wasted decades, that large parts of everyone's identity, everyone's affiliation,
情感系统仍在感知指标无法感知的东西。哀悼是从伪装到现实的通道，从镜像到现实，从鬼魂到亡者。但它们感觉像鬼魂的原因是我们疏离了。为了感知亡者而不是与鬼魂交谈，我们必须停止对真正现实的东西进行疏离。这意味着承认我们浪费了几十年，承认每个人的身份、每个人的归属感、
everybody's map of the future wasn't really real, because it wasn't really ours. But we mistook it for something that we thought was real, just like the Gnostings, generations. Enormous amounts of human potential, channeled into optimizing metrics that didn't connect anything real. You have to feel that, and you have to hurt. Because students taught to pass tests instead of thinking is scary. And experts trained in models that don't describe reality, institutions that lost their purpose and forgot they ever had one. That's awful.
每个人的未来地图的很大一部分并不是真正真实的，因为它不是真正属于我们的。但我们把它误认为是某种我们认为真实的东西，就像诺斯替教徒一样，几代人。巨大的人类潜力被引导去优化那些与任何真实事物无关的指标。你必须感受到这一点，你必须感到痛苦。因为教导学生通过考试而不是思考是可怕的。专家受训于不描述现实的模型，机构失去了目的并忘记了它们曾经有过目的。那太糟糕了。
And to admit that feels crazy. It feels like I'm insane. You know, this means sitting with that loss without immediately reaching for a solution. Without rushing to the next grand narrative, without oscillating into infinite complexity. Just sitting with the weight of what's been squandered here. It means hearing the dead, not the ghosts, the dead. The teachers who knew the difference. The practitioners who understood what craft was for.
承认这一点感觉很疯狂。感觉就像我疯了一样。你知道，这意味着要与那种失落感共处，而不是立即寻求解决方案。不急于寻找下一个宏大的叙事，也不在无限的复杂性中摇摆不定。只是静静地感受这里被浪费掉的东西的重量。这意味着倾听死者，不是鬼魂，而是死者。那些知道其中区别的老师们。那些理解技艺为何物的实践者们。
The traditions that carried actual wisdom. before they were converted into data and hearing their questions, feeling their demands, acknowledging what we failed to transmit. It means trusting the emotional knowing that's been dismissed, feeling the wrongness that metrics can't capture, and letting the body tell us what the model never could. Because that's the only way to re-engage with where history stopped moving forward, with where we forgot that we had a responsibility to everything that was left
那些承载着真正智慧的传统，在它们被转化为数据之前，倾听他们的问题，感受他们的要求，承认我们未能传承的东西。这意味着信任那些一直被忽视的情感认知，感受那些指标无法捕捉的错误，并让身体告诉我们模型永远无法告诉我们的东西。因为这是重新参与历史停止前进的地方，以及我们忘记了对留下的所有事物负有责任的唯一途径。
unfinished by the generations before us. And sometimes that means admitting how far your generation has failed to move the ball. Hillman called his book Lament of the Dead. A lament is a particular form. It's not an analysis. It's not an argument. It's not a solution or a policy or a metric. It's not a prescription. A lament is grief given voice. The acknowledgement of loss. The sound a soul makes when it finally allows itself to feel what has been taken. And we need lament, not wallow, not despair, but acknowledging the reality of what we've lost so that something new can begin. The mirror can't lament. It can only optimize. It can only measure. It can only reflect. But we are not the mirror. We are the consciousness that knows despite everything. That the institutions were
那是前几代人未完成的。有时这意味着承认你们这一代人在推动进步方面失败了多少。希尔曼把他的书称为《死者的哀歌》。哀歌是一种特殊的形式。它不是分析。它不是论点。它不是解决方案、政策或指标。它不是处方。哀歌是发出的悲伤。是对失落的承认。当灵魂终于允许自己感受被夺走的东西时所发出的声音。我们需要哀歌，不是沉溺，不是绝望，而是承认我们所失去的现实，以便新的事物能够开始。镜子无法哀悼。它只能优化。它只能测量。它只能反射。但我们不是镜子。我们是尽管一切仍知晓的意识。那些机构本应
supposed to represent something that was real. And it can be real again. And we are the ones who can still fill the gap between the metric and the meaning. And even if we can't always articulate it, we are emotional beings whose emotional systems are always articulating it to us. Telling us the truth that if we can learn to hear that through the noise, we can be okay. The dead are always speaking. Not the ghosts. Not the patterns in the data, the statistical averages. the actual voices of the dead.
代表某种真实的东西。而且它可以再次变得真实。我们是那些仍然可以填补指标和意义之间鸿沟的人。即使我们不能总是清晰地表达出来，我们也是情感生物，我们的情感系统总是在向我们表达它。告诉我们真相，如果我们能学会穿过噪音听到它，我们就能好起来。死者一直在说话。不是鬼魂。不是数据中的模式，不是统计平均值。而是死者真实的声音。
The ones who knew what education was for before tests colonized it, the ones who practiced crafts that can't be credentialed, the ones whose questions are now our questions, whose unlived life presses on us. To hear them, we have to stop pretending that the mirror is enough, and to answer them we have to admit how much we've lost, and to carry their unfinished work forward,
那些在考试殖民教育之前就知道教育为何物的人，那些实践无法被认证的技艺的人，那些人的问题现在成了我们的问题，他们未竟的生活压在我们身上。为了听到他们，我们必须停止假装镜子就足够了，为了回答他们，我们必须承认我们失去了多少，并继续完成他们未竟的工作，
we have to grieve what they couldn't complete, and then complete it. This is the work, not another metric, not another institution, not another grand narrative, or infinite complexity. Not another LLM that performs understanding without understanding anything, just this, looking away from the mirror, finding the territory inside of you again, the divine spark in the desert, sitting with the weight of the dead, trusting the emotional system that knows what the models can't see, and beginning finally to grieve. What lies on the other side of that grief? I can't promise. But I know that what lies on this side?
我们必须为他们无法完成的事情感到悲伤，然后完成它。这就是工作，不是另一个指标，不是另一个机构，不是另一个宏大的叙事，或无限的复杂性。不是另一个在不理解任何东西的情况下表现出理解的LLM，只是这个，从镜子上移开目光，再次找到你内心的领土，沙漠中的神圣火花，与死者的重量共处，信任那个知道模型无法看到的东西的情感系统，并最终开始悲伤。在那份悲伤的另一边是什么？我无法保证。但我知道在这一边是什么？
The oscillation is continuing and the shock remaining permanent. The mirror reflecting itself forever. The dead converted into ghosts. And the dime on silence by noise. And the emotional truth dismissed as a rationality. We cannot stay here. The lament is how we leave. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
震荡在继续，冲击依然存在。镜子永远反射着自身。死者变成了鬼魂。噪音掩盖了沉默。情感真相被视为非理性。我们不能留在这里。哀歌是我们离开的方式。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。